and uh on my home page uh
if you if you go to computer musings it
tells you always what the status of
these it's a series that i started
several years ago and uh usually the
lectures are impromptu that means that i
i make them up as i go along and uh i i
know i have something neat to talk about
but i but uh i don't necessarily have it
i'm
real well prepared uh
but today is a little different um
uh today uh i'm going to sort of repeat
a talk that i gave at uh
uh in july at the siame there was a big
meeting of siam organization here um
and uh gene golov asked me two or three
years ago if i would if i would give a
talk at that time
and so of course uh
after you know three years in the future
i would say yeah sure i'll do it
and
and then it got to be
closer and closer and then i realized i
ought to maybe
maybe uh uh
say something uh uh
non-trivial if i had so many people
watching so so then i i gave the lecture
and it went okay but now i thought well
good luck you might as well give it
twice get some mileage out of it so i'm
doing it again today
um
now what what have i got in my hands
here uh it turns out that uh
uh
that i
that i get a whole bunch of reprints of
articles that i've written and uh and i
don't get that many requests for them uh
so uh so i'm giving you thought as
handouts to anybody uh
uh now
actually actually some of these uh deal
with uh talks that i've given previously
in this series uh but anyway uh but but
also there's this uh
uh this sheet which tells you that if
that uh
last two days to buy my book at a
fifteen percent discount at the
bookstore right things like that um uh
you can also get a whole issue if you're
quick enough of the journal of algebraic
combinatorics which had two of my papers
in it so
um
so so i got a bunch of defense that are
sitting here
what i do is i
i save out ten things for
10 of them for requests that'll that
might come in the mail and then but they
send me 100 so what am i going to do
with 100 so
uh
i don't know i i was interested in all
this stuff when i wrote it so you might
um
but
but now i gotta i gotta figure out how
i'm gonna do my talk today because uh
uh when i first when i gave it at the
cyan meeting i gave it with an overhead
projector and we don't have an overhead
projector here so instead we've got an
overhead camera so i'm going to try
putting this slide here
and see what happens on the overhead
camera does this work
let's see actually i have this over so
i'm going to try yeah
so so can we get that on the uh
on a tv
and then we can dim the lights and
so so so after after the lecture come up
come up here and help yourself to these
uh uh reprints only only three per
customer uh of any one particular one
um okay now let's see yeah let's see
we don't need the uh
i guess maybe you need a light in order
to see this huh on your camera
uh but i i don't know if the audience
can see that very well
so we gotta get we gotta get this
technology
let's turn off the lights
focusing on okay well anyway this is my
title 35 years of of
of linear probing
um
okay now let's see how is that
that's the frame size i'm going to have
to work with here too
uh i guess i can i guess i can do that
yeah
right like this one here
guys don't get involved with inventing a
new language
because we can't wait
all right so um
anyway guys if you could figure out a
way to to
dim the lights a little bit but still
see that that picture that would be nice
okay anyway this is the talk that i this
is the uh the web advert for the talk
that in the abstract of it and uh the
and uh 35 years of linear probing uh 35
it turns out that in july of this year
almost exactly
uh 32 years to the day of uh of an
experience in my life that that changed
my life in in the in the summer of 1962
i was writing a fortran compiler
and uh i
had uh
one day i i sat down and i tried and i
tried to
to analyze the message that i was using
in that compiler to look up the names of
the variables
uh and that method is now called linear
probing
and uh and as i i'll tell you the story
about why it changed my life and
everything but but but basically uh uh
that was the 35 years leading to uh
onto this july and and i've been probing
ever since and uh and linear probing is
part of the story and i want to try to
tell it
now um
i also
put a cursor here so that we could click
on
on what's cool
so
and what's cool is
analysis of alg whoa
analysis of algorithm this is the this
is my been my life's work ever since
1962.
um
and uh
uh well there's another connection with
with the siam organization because
because uh
uh in the 60s
okay in 1952 i was a graduate i was a
grad student and at caltech and anyway i
i started i got my phd in math and i
stayed in the math department
and i um
and i went to uh to a siam meeting in
1967 that's uh the fall of 67 is about
exactly 30 years ago
and i remember being at the banquet at
that scion meeting and
people asked me what i was interested in
and you know i said well i'm
uh
computer science and they said oh um
numerical analysis and i said well no
not really um
artificial intelligence
and uh and i said well no uh so then it
says oh then you must be a languages man
uh programming language um and uh
uh well all computer science in the 60s
was divided into three parts like gall
you know in roman times where uh there
was a numerical analysis ai and
programming languages well i i was
interested in programming languages i
had
had was editor of the
of the communications section on program
language of things but that was that's
but what i really considered my life's
work was something different but there
wasn't a name for it and so after that
banquet the discussion i realized that
if i'm going to have if i'm going to
explain what i do to other people i'm
going to have to have a name for it
and that night i i said okay i'm going
to call it analysis of algorithm
uh now now if anybody asked me to define
what was analysis of algorithms my only
definition was it was what i liked
uh
you know i had to come up with a real
meaning for it later on
um
a definition but but uh first of all
anyway i i i i
it was it was basically what i thought
uh what was cool about the computer
science and uh what's turned out to be
is
that uh it's it's where i take an
algorithms and analyze them
uh which means that i try to find the
quantitative
properties of the algorithm i try to
find out how good it is in some way that
that i i don't only say is pretty good
but i say it's that one method is you
know 6.2 better than another method
and uh that kind of uh work has led them
to a great many fascinating problems
that that i think uh are are
beautiful and interesting and and uh i
realized at that time
even in 1962 when i first analyzed
the linear probing algorithm i'll be
talking about later
i realized how much fun it was
to have
to have analyzed this hashing method
that i was looking at
and
and uh that uh that this was only one
out of uh
out of thousands and thousands of
algorithms uh and i knew that
i knew that there was already a science
of queuing theory which was which had
lots of people working in it full time
and queuing was only one
small family of algorithms and so so i
thought oh boy take all the possible
algorithms you can you can think of and
imagine analyzing them that's certainly
more than you know that's more than
enough to do in one lifetime and it
should be a lot of fun and um that's
later what i decided i'd call analysis
of algorithm
um now
so i called my publishers and i said i
want to change the title of my book
instead of calling it art of computer
programming let's call it the analysis
of algorithms
uh well they say they said no no that'll
never sell okay
so
so i had to uh
go back actually our computer program is
pretty nice name anyway but um i'm glad
to see that uh
in 1995
there is a book coming out analysis of
algorithms oxford press by nathan
harford
and uh last year
uh
yeah this
lovely book
by cedric and flagellate
uh
i guess it will have to get
a little less zoomed out yeah that's
pretty that's good and and this book
came out last year um
very nice book about the introduction to
the subject so so they
i i've been i've been pretty lucky this
uh
this title analysis of algorithms uh has
has caught on
and uh other people seem to like it too
now what i want to tell you about
uh
about my life's 35 years of my life's
work all in one in one hour today and
actually i had to do it in 40 minutes at
the siam meeting
uh it was a siam's 40th meeting and so
they gave every speaker 40 minutes
now
but i'm going to do mathematicians
aren't fun
so i'm going to do it by illustrating
the first algorithm i analyzed and and
that shows you a lot about the whole
subject
and
the algorithm that
that
i started with is actually
uh also known to many people under
another name musical chairs
uh so let's imagine we have in this case
uh 10 chairs
and i've got
i'm going to put um
another number up here you're going to
be able to see it uh can we go
just a little back you'll be uh yeah a
little bit more i'm going to write one
more line well here i i'll
i'll yeah i'll give myself a little room
and now you're okay so
so now um
let me let me show you what musical
chairs is in the computer
linear probing fashion this is the
algorithm called linear probing um it's
very simple but it turns out still use
it a lot uh for example in the text
system every time you try to hyphenate a
word it uses this algorithm to to figure
out if it's an exceptional word if it
was in your list of
special words
so uh let's see i'll take a red pin i
guess
so um what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to insert nine items or nine
people into these ten chairs the chariot
number zero one to nine
and the arrangement circle and the first
person goes into
chair three
so there it is
he gets
into three
then
now the next person
uh goes into position one
and the third person goes into position
four this is all pretty simple but but
now it gets interesting the fourth
person wants to go into position into
chair number one also
so in general when anybody comes and
wants to take a seat
we say they come
at a random place around the circle
and um i i use the digits of pi here
because that's about as random as
anything
um i i don't know if i need a random
number that's my first choice always so
so um uh so so this guy number four
wants to go into position one but that's
already full so he goes uh he goes on
and and goes into position two instead
but i'm still gonna put a one there
because that's what
that's the home address
uh the next next guy wants to go into
five that's okay no problem
next guy into nine uh easy
next one into two oops that's taken
so the two is now going to have to slide
around all the way around here
okay
and um
uh
okay the next one six that that's taken
but just a little bit and goes here
and finally five and that's going to
mean coming up to here
and going into position five
so that's uh
that's linear probing
uh usually we don't use it inside a
computer when the table see i didn't
oh here i actually have this slide
already written out and advanced real
nice so i'll replace it by a good one
yeah there you go
ah
okay so um
uh now we usually don't want to use it
until the when the table gets all the
way full
because uh as you notice at the end uh
i left out that same the same one
interesting
oh wait that's because there wasn't
nobody ever carried over from one place
to the other side
from that place to the other i'm just
the uh the inefficiency of the method is
the number of these of these extra extra
times when somebody had had to move on
to the next chair
um it's most of the hashing is most
efficient if you're in your home
position of course and then they and uh
so the displacement from your home
position that's what you that's what we
uh are worried about when i was uh first
uh
learning how to use a computer back in
the 50s
uh uh the the machine i used was
uh well the average the ad time was i
think uh something like four
milliseconds
uh and so uh uh
when it was using hashing the table
would start to fill up you could see the
lights goes this is like that you know
you you could all of a sudden see and
and then uh uh we would be uh uh running
out
running a program every once while the
machine would stop and and the lights
would spin and you would see oh yeah
linear probing taking it now it's going
to it's filling up the table um
uh and there was a rumor that
some students of
professor feller at princeton had tried
to analyze linear probing and find out
you know how
uh how much time is it going to spend
spinning um and that they that they they
failed and so uh naturally uh uh
i thought it was too hard and i didn't
try it um
but this one but during the summer of 62
which is a 35 years ago which is the
beginning of my story um
i had this this data kill uh where i was
i was implementing this linear probing
in my fortran compiler
and i
i just couldn't resist uh trying to to
see if i couldn't figure out uh how how
slow it would go
and uh
uh and i got lucky and and came up with
the
with the answer
um and as i said uh uh it was it was fun
it was exhilarating you know to know
that uh that i could that i could uh
solve this problem
and uh and i could see that many other
algorithms uh from the horizon
um so
uh
oh that's uh
uh 1962. now
uh
in order to attack something like this
and find out how
how it really works um
what i what i usually do is uh is just
um
start small and i go exhaustively uh
through the small cases of the problem
until i until i can get some idea what's
going on so here's an example suppose i
have a table that's not 10 slots in it
but only three slots in it or four slots
i'm sorry
and um
i'm
oh
and i'm going to consider putting three
things into four slots
but i'm only going to consider the case
that uh
uh
that none of them go into zero we can we
can shift everything around
um
well
and anyway um
let's put
let's look at this example so if i have
one one one that means that everybody
has home position one and so uh
the displacement of the first guy is
zero second guy has to move one space
the third guy has to move two spaces
total of three uh a displacement if it's
three if if it's one two three everybody
goes into their home position there's no
displacement so you can work it out you
find out that uh
there's one case where the total is
placed into three
six cases where there's no displacement
at all and there's six cases where
there's one and three case where there's
two so you can work it work out the uh
the complete system here systematically
and um
uh here i've written it as a polynomial
just to to indicate uh the total number
of cases six uh with with
six x to the zero means six cases where
where there's zero displacement and so
on
um and you can do that uh this is in
fine print that the tv will never show
it but uh
that's okay
the point is that
we get this small print we can still get
to a large print polynomial here which
says that if we try putting three things
into six slots we get 60 cases
of the one case and then 36 9
and three
now um and uh
this was
sort of the way i started looking at it
and trying to find out where these
numbers came from
now
um
let's let's uh
i want to show you something from the
art of computer programming
some of you know that i wrote a book
called the art of computer program
uh
this is uh
uh volume three which uh
uh well i started writing line three in
uh in 1962 actually i i signed the
contract for this whole series in the
january of 62 and and i thought i would
have it done by 64.
and that and actually i have letters
from 1964 saying i'm sorry i can't
visit stanford this summer because i
have to finish my book first
but uh uh because
uh four sides asked me to
give it anyway so this is uh
uh uh but but in this book i um in this
series i uh
in audition i didn't have any footnotes
throughout the first three volumes
except in one place
i i i broke down and i and i put a
foothold on this part in the part at the
end of volume three where i'm talking
about hashing
um
and uh well that's uh
i actually i can blow it up to
to show you what the footnote is
so i'll read it i'll read you this
footnote the author cannot
resist inserting a biographical note at
this point i first formulated the
following derivation 1962 shortly after
beginning work on the art of computer
programming since this was the first
non-trivial algorithm i'd ever analyzed
satisfactorily
has had a strong influence on the
structure of these books little did i
know that more than 10 years would go by
before this derivation got into print
and
i found in my files uh some some type
notes that i made a year later
uh this is data in 63 where i where i
took where i
wrote down the solution
i transcribed it from my handwritten
notes at that time
the solution of this uh of this problem
and how i and how i solved it and uh you
know and i had tables in there which
where i had
analyzed the case of five
uh
slots in detail and then i had formulas
that would go to the general case of the
average so this was uh uh as i said a a
life-changing experience for me to have
had a little success on this but now if
you look at this new book by cedric and
flagellate which is a great book on
analysis of algorithms it's very
interesting that near the end of the
book they have
they have
where they have this page where they
start disc they discuss linear probing
and um
they give some some formulas here
and uh
and and it says uh
despite that what i what i saw was the
average number of
the average amount of this displacement
it says despite the relatively simple
form of the solution the derivation for
the average cost
of linear probing using generating
functions and the symbolic method has
not yet been worked out
now what do they mean generating
functions in the symbolic method this is
the
the whole idea of
of
new stuff in the analysis of algorithms
uh is a wonderful thing called the
symbolic method and and and the book of
flashlight cedric is a great
introduction to the symbolic method
which uh which solves all kinds of
algorithms in a very in a very nice way
much easier than my my uh brute force uh
way that i used in the 60s and
and so now
basically
most of the classical algorithms that
are known to be analyzable well are
actually analyzed best by means of this
symbolic method uh but but linear
clothing no
and and so it's so they have an exercise
here i got a close-up of this they have
an exercise here that says
use the symbolic method to derive the
the
exponential generating function of the
number of probes required by linear
probing and they have a footnote here
the temptation to include one footnote
at this point can't be resisted
we don't know the answer to this
exercise okay
so
so um so this caught my eye
when when the book came out a year ago
and uh
and uh
okay so so uh
now let me say a little bit more about
the symbolic method there's a new
there's another book coming out very
soon it's advertised on the web here um
of by cambridge press uh the translation
from french i have the french version
which came out two or three years ago
and uh uh and uh it should come out any
day i looked at the i looked today at
socrates and the bookstore still doesn't
uh list this but um it should should be
out soon uh and uh the new uh term for
this symbolic method is species common
tourist species now you might not
believe this but i but but maybe ten
years from now undergraduates are going
to be learning about species it's a it's
a beautiful idea it's a beautiful
concept it allows you to allows a lot of
things to
that people
uh found laboriously over the years to
to be understood in a nice algebraic
clean way
to study all kinds of combinatorial uh
things including running times of
computer program
um so look for this book sometime uh i'm
hoping that i'll get a free copy if i
advertise it well enough but i mean it's
a very
but the french the french version is uh
is certainly uh is certainly good and i
think they've added new stuff also for
the english translation now i'm going to
show you a few examples of the symbolic
method as we as we go on
because my problem now you see was to
try to figure out how to style linear
probing that i had done in 62
the modern way instead of the
old-fashioned way it's what we we've got
these better tools we should be able to
at least solve the old problems right
and go further
because in because still was was open
um
we knew the average number of probes
done by linear probing but we didn't
know the variance we didn't know the
average number of the square we didn't
know how how wild this this thing
behaves the average number much simpler
in many problems than the variance but
in this case uh the variance wasn't that
nobody even had
a tool for how to calculate the variance
if we knew the symbolic method we'd be
able to get the variance pretty easy
so um that's why i wrote this as a
polynomial
and i have this polynomial f with two
parameters m n which is this which uh
where i take x to the total displacement
and i sum that over all ways of putting
n
keys into m cells like n people into m
slots uh leaving the first cell empty i
i uh i'm always saying that that one
cell i'm going to leave empty because uh
we can um assume that that one of them
is going to be empty
um and
and then i i list here the cases where
uh
where there's only one empty all and m
minus one uh you know n is is equal to m
minus one so that there's one empty slot
and n
full slots
um and these are the the polynomial that
we have
and uh
the symbolic method tells us that what
we should do is
is form a double generating function
with two
with two variables x and z
where where in the in in the z's we
should divide by factorials
uh so here we in other words it would be
the sum of f n plus 1 n
of x this polynomial uh that i have here
times e to the n over n factorial now uh
the reason for the factorial is um
as you learned with the symbolic method
is that it it means that when you
multiply two of these symbolic
expressions together it corresponds to
taking two objects and putting them next
to each other
um
and and the factorials make everything
everything uh check out well
you have to believe that on faith now
but uh but basically uh it means that if
i if i take f this function f
uh which corresponds to having one
unoccupied
one unoccupied slot and i raise it to
the r power
so i multiply it by itself r times then
it gives me all the configurations where
i have um
one
unoccupied slot followed by another
followed by another part of another so a
total of our unoccupied slots
and uh so so i can get the general case
for our unoccupied slots by taking the
one slot case and raising it to the r
power
for example if i if i calculate the
third power
it turns out that uh
uh
that
you know and and of course now we have
these wonderful
programs like mathematica and maple that
will that will multiply these uh power
series out real fast and we can take a
look and do all kind of experiments and
check out and see uh exactly what these
what these are and so for example if i
cube this and look at the coefficient of
z cubed over six uh it turns out to be
60 plus 36x plus 9x squared plus 3x
cubed that's the the thing i i
found before by brute force
uh
listing all of these guys
that was this slide here so i had just
that polynomial so that
the meaning is in that polynomial is
really
uh what you get by looking at the
coefficient of z cubed over six
if you cube the polynomial that
corresponds to the to the other one f so
if i'm going to
understand linear probing by the
symbolic method uh f is the key to the
thing
and i just have to then i take the
powers of f and then i have to look at
what it is but what if what is this f i
mean i just defined it what but i don't
know i mean these are numbers that we
can that we can uh check out but where
do they where do they come from
um well
before i get into that let me show you
how i get the answer once i know if i
know f
then
then um
if i know fmn
and with that where x is this uh
this number that i i just used in there
to uh
so that the x to the k is used when the
displacement is k
uh if i divide by f by the same thing
divide by setting x equal to one then i
get the probability uh the the
coefficient of xq will be the
probability that the displacement is
three
um because i've taken the total number
of ways divided by
i mean the total number of ways will
displacement three divided by total
number of ways with displacement
anything so that's the denominators
total number of ways
the numerator is is uh has powers of x
to show it and then we can calculate the
average displacement by take by taking
the derivative with respect to x that
brings that brings down um the uh uh you
know if it's x to the d then i have i
bring down a d and d is going to be
multiplied by the probability so i'll
get uh
d times the probability that it was
equal to d that gives me the average
value
uh similarly to get the the average of
the square displacement uh we we we take
second derivative
and uh
and uh so this is the way we can go from
a generating function uh to the other
all right now um
uh almost exactly a year ago today i was
i was reading a paper that
someone had
directed my attention to in preparation
for volume four of the art of computer
programming and uh
and uh lo and behold
oh okay here's the paper
it's a it's uh
it's in french by uh
by dr cruz i don't pronounce his name
very well but he says a family of
polynomials having many
enumerative properties
and
it's a very descriptive title as you can
see it's a paper i never would have read
unless somebody
uh told me about it it's not in a
it's in periodic mathematica hungarica
not a journal that i ordinarily look at
now um
now uh but anyway uh look here's the
polynomials
and here you know t cubed plus three t
squared plus six t plus six well i mean
you turn that around and you have six
plus six x plus three you know you have
to change t to x but uh uh
uh but there they were uh so uh but but
he didn't get these pronominals from
hashing he didn't know anything about
hashing
uh well maybe he did but he didn't
uh think about hashing when he wrote
this paper um uh and so uh and so
great that you know so so this was uh
this was one notch for understanding so
these are the these are the are the
missing components in my in my uh
uh super polynomial x f
um
so what when i saw this paper uh well
and i i saw the interpretation that
kuros gave to these polynomials uh i i
knew that i was
that
it would only take me about uh
you know less than a day to finish the
analysis of linear probing and uh i
thought this would be great but um i'm
supposed to be working on the art of
computer programming not doing research
anymore so i didn't have time to finish
it so instead i wrote a letter to
flagelle and cedric and i said look i
found this wonderful paper of course
explains what this is here's the
symbolic method is going to solve it uh
you know a student can do this now in a
couple hours and uh and uh
or at least maybe you and maybe you guys
can do it um and uh so i wrote him a
letter explaining this uh and i and i
expected to to to get a letter back a
week later with their what they're
saying yes it's well it's it's great don
here's the here it is and now it's no we
got the symbolic method the problem is
solved uh uh
well but uh actually months went by and
i didn't get any reply at all
and uh and so i was wondering if they
were sick or something you know so i so
i
so i wrote so i wrote i wrote the letter
and said hey did you get my letter did
you receive yeah it says oh yeah yeah we
i uh we're going to take a look at it
when we go to spain uh you know so so it
turned out they were busy too and didn't
occur didn't occur to me that somebody
else would be busy too
so um
uh
well
uh
more more time went on you know in
january i i i
i i i was past my deadline for the siam
uh to give a title for for for my paper
at siam meeting uh the uh
the deadline was supposed to be january
1 and i wrote to the i wrote saying well
i was hoping to present a new result
about linear probing but i don't know uh
yet whether or not there will be any any
action on this uh uh so so what's the
absolute deadline and how long can i
wait you know so they said oh
and and i sent a copy to uh uh to cedric
and flagler and say any news any news
and uh
and uh
actually i had mapped the whole
nice program out in my letter a two-page
letter it's very clear and everything
but i i didn't hear a word from them
um so
time went on and you know the siam
program was issued and it said title to
be announced you know and so
and uh it was the week before i'm giving
my talk in july and i said and i figured
okay uh this is my this is the
uh
i can't wait any longer i'm gonna have
to sit down and actually try to figure
out the the last step myself and uh and
sure enough uh uh uh it was
you know the clincher was there and i
got and i and you know and i i solved
the problem and it's and it is beautiful
you'll see in a minute uh
that that it all that all hangs together
and ties together lots of lots of other
uh uh other work um
and uh and i called uh cedric uh to tell
him the good news
and i and uh i called princeton and uh
and uh the secretary said he's he's out
and uh and so i said well um you know
i'm his professor uh uh can you give me
his home phone no we don't give that
information you know so anyway well but
then finally i i tracked him down like
that he was in rhode island on vacation
um and uh i reached his wife
and she said oh
bob has just left
for the airport don't go to a conference
in jury in in germany
you missed him by an hour
and uh unfortunately he took the car
without a cell phone
so i can't reach him um because i really
wanted to to know whether there was any
progress on this
uh no wait i'm sorry i got this run this
was before i had done the work this was
when i was just desperate to see if they
were going to solve it before i could do
i wanted to i wanted them to solve it so
i could announce that they had solved it
um
that's right and uh and so no so he had
left for the airport and so i so that's
when i just broke down and decided to
work on it myself and the next day i had
the solution i wrote email to the
conference uh
and sent and and told him about it and
that was very interesting you know he
said and and uh oh and linda bob's wife
told me the reason why he hadn't
answered any of my letters he said he's
been working night and day on his new
book algorithms in c
and in fact i just got that book uh last
week and it's it's it's it's wonderful
so no wonder he uh he completely wrote
his book on algorithms and uh and uh uh
has a you know a thousand new exercises
in it and all kinds of stuff so he
all kind of knew illustrations and he
and so no wonder he didn't have time to
answer mail or anything and you know he
was he was a hermit just like i am so
so uh
so he finally got to this conference
where he's going to rest for you know
for and
and i reached him at the conference and
he said oh that's very interesting that
you solved the problem uh because two
guys here at the conference solved the
same problem last week
and uh sure enough
uh i got this this message um from from
uh
uh
dr viola and and and and
these are uh
from
south america chile and uruguay i think
and uh they had there's they were uh uh
have been working in an analysis wagons
for for a long time there's a very
strong uh group in south america working
on these problems and uh they got uh uh
and they presented me the
their their answer uh and so we could
check our answers that we got the same
answers
kind of a hairy formula uh but this
would be the the the
uh
the formula that they came up with well
um
okay well i was scooped as far as
getting the answer first was concerned
but uh it was nice to know that in fact
the symbolic method was uh sufficiently
well developed that uh
that it led to to to uh
two solutions almost exactly
simultaneously
and uh uh also it turned out uh that
uh that
their solution was was done sort of
by brute force while mine was done more
cleverly without explaining so so i
could still be happy uh no but but
anyway um uh there was a
anyway our solutions although we got the
same answer uh we took different paths
and both paths are interesting and so
that's uh that's turned out to be
interesting too but now let me let me uh
explain what the uh some of the ideas of
the solution and the way it connects
with other things because this is
this is uh
the kind of thing that turns me on and i
hope some of you will will realize why
um now here's uh
here's the uh reason why crew is the
frenchman uh uh
had come up with those polynomials uh if
you here i i'm listing all trees for an
example on four on four points
and uh on four labeled points so i have
points zero one two and three and i and
there's 16 ways to connect uh uh connect
them into a tree
um
and uh with each tree i've uh i've put
underneath it in green here the number
of inversions so-called in the tree now
uh if you look at it enough you'll see
what inversions are it means that if you
take the path to zero uh you've gone uh
uh you you make a step
downward
so
this so from one to zero drops down once
and from two to zero drops down once
from three zero dots and ones three
inversions total here here's the case
three two one zero no nothing dropping
down here's a case where there's a
dropping down from two to zero
uh here's the k you know so that was
with each with each uh
tree you you
follow the path down to zero which is
the which you consider to be the root
element of the tree and you see how many
times you uh uh
uh uh you you drop down
actually how many pairs how many pairs
there are that are out of order
um in the in in the tree
uh so um
uh this is the
if you if you look at uh at these 16
cases
uh and count the inversions you get the
same polynomial that i got uh when i was
studying linear probing and putting uh
three things into four slides
uh with with says with slot zero empty
now uh
i had
uh after i read cruz's paper i i was
working on an exercise in volume three
uh where
where it talks about uh inversions of
trees and and so i found a nice
correspondence
that would prove the connection between
those two problems
all right i can't give you the details
but i'll
give you some of the the flavor of it
here's the
here's the example we did before with
with pie uh but i but i i i
changed the columns so that the the
instead of instead of having them in
order by the blue numbers uh one two
three four five i've had them in order
by the green numbers the final the blue
numbers are the order in which the
people arrived for that musical chairs
the green numbers are the order in which
they finally are sitting in the chairs
um and uh
uh so this is the the final place and
the red numbers are the numbers that was
their home position so the difference
between the green and the red number is
the displacement like if somebody's in
chair six has started at two he's got
displacement of four
so a total of nine displacements in that
example
and
um if there's a relation between these
musical chairs and inversions and trees
i should be able to find the tree that
corresponds to this and here's how and
here's how you do it you look at this at
the um
at the permutation first of all you look
at the permutation of the blue num of
the
blue numbers and you and you find uh
places where it's sort of go where it's
sort of uh increasing
nicely so here's like one three five
seven eight nine and that goes into the
tree one three five seven eight nine
and then there's a two four
five seven eight nine is another
path that comes through here and so i'll
hook the uh they sort of share the five
so so
uh basically there's a fairly simple
rule to get from the blue numbers to the
tree
that i have uh that i have here but this
is this is a tree that uh of the special
kind where all the paths uh are always
going upwards up up up up and except
when they get to the uh to the zero root
so that's not the answer to the to a
problem of of a certain number
of um
inversions corresponding to a certain
number of displacements however i put in
parenthesis here the number of
displacements that i that i'm supposed
to get like this four is supposed to
have one displacement uh the the five is
supposed to have no displacements the
seven is supposed to have four
displacements okay so um i have to find
a tree that that uh somehow corresponds
to this one but has has that many
inversions in it and you can work on you
can work on this tree from the leaves
down to the root uh until uh and and and
and swapping uh numbers around and so
like when you get to a seven it says i
wanna get have four displacements for it
so you sort of move it uh uh four steps
down so that it's gonna it's gonna
displacing and anyway to make a long
story short it turns out here here it is
uh
uh that the um that uh there will be
four displacements uh uh of course i
mean the total number of displacements
uh the total number of inversions
industry is nine and this tree from this
tree i could go back and recompute this
and recompute this and so i would get a
a scenario on musical chairs that has
the same number of displacements as this
has inversion so uh
in in general then there's a there's a
there's a fairly simple um not trivial
but still fairly simple way to convert
between
my
uh musical chairs my linear probing and
uh trees that have a certain number of
inversions
now the the the uh
the story of inversions on trees
uh goes back to the 60s 1967
paper here by
mallos and riordan
about inversions in trees and they were
the first people to and to notice that
uh that there was some
some reasonably nice mathematical
properties about inversions and trees
and uh they and in their paper they uh
uh
they found uh uh some some polynomials
that uh that
that were suggested to them and they
started working on it so so uh the uh
beginning of this
of this step of the symbolic method uh
goes back to the 60s
there's another interesting paper that
came out in the 70s
uh and that was
at mit
um
ira gesso
and one of his students darwin wong who
people tell me is now
a rich man in new jersey working on
on communications networks
he
they discovered a beautiful
correspondence uh between inversions of
trees and graphs uh you know graph
theory
and i want to show you what what
gesellen long discovered in the 70s
here's the tree that i had a minute ago
that had nine inversions
and i said it corresponded to my musical
chairs
now
in this tree i have drawn
an orange line um
for the let's see now
what how did i draw it i went from one
to two
i think uh what i did is whenever the um
let's take a look it's got to be simple
so seven nine so if i if i come from a
path down here then seven is inverting
one two and four
uh so there's a line from seven to one
seven to two but and and one to four
that doesn't work
um
okay so um
huh should be easy well let me tell you
the the next part of the story and then
it then might come up
um come about so so uh
uh if i start with hashing n things into
n plus one slots and have d g
displacements then as i said a minute
ago i get a tree that has n plus one
vertices and d inversions now i'm
supposed i want to get a connection
between trees and gra and connected
graphs
and there's a and when you study graph
algorithms uh computer scientists uh the
the most important algorithm they learn
is what's called depth first search in
the graph
and the idea of depth first search is
you start somewhere
in the graph and you start exploring the
graph by looking
by looking to see if uh if there's any
uh edges uh any vertices that you have
that that you don't know yet uh uh
reachable from where you are if so you
go there uh imagine you're exploring a
cave or you're or you're in some
adventure game or something you go into
uh yeah and every time you see a
a place you haven't been you go there uh
and then you keep on going until you've
explored all of all the places you can
get to then you go back and you go
and and you go and you're back and you
backtrack and then you continue
exploring uh previously now uh you have
to have some order in which to do this
in this particular case uh uh the the
i started at vertex zero and it has two
um it has two uh places to go either
four or six i think maybe i'll i'll take
the smaller one first so i'll go first
from zero to four then i'll check this
four have any
anything else coming out of it and it
might have two now but you can also add
the add the
orange the orange arcs which are all
supposed to be less than
six oh okay
i i guess maybe i'm supposed to go first
to the sixth and then i and then six has
nothing so i come back at zero then i
then i go next to the next highest one
and that's four even if i had
what these orange one like a zero to two
or zero to one or zero to three i would
still choose four as the next place to
explore in this cave
uh from four i can either go to two or
to one i'll take the largest one is two
from two i can go to eight or two five
three
one or seven eight is the biggest so i
go to eight and eight i i i have only
one so i have to go to one from one i
have
three nine
zero four
nine is the biggest so i go to nine and
so on i continue exploring after i get
to the seven i'll come back to the one
and i'll do it it turns out that whether
any of these orange arcs are are there
or not i'm going to get exactly this
tree
as the depth first search that i do
and um
and the way the orange ones were put on
had to do with the inversions of the
thing and it was something like
when there was a inversion let's see if
i had to
what i didn't just draw right from the
inversion but something like go to the
parent and then go and then go to the
and then draw it so
like nine to zero probably cause caused
me to get the ones but i i don't
remember the rule anyway there is a rule
that will go directly from any tree with
d inversions
to
drawing um
uh d orange lines in here and any of
this take and and and uh
uh any of the graphs that have uh
that have um all of the orange lines or
none of them or any subset of the orange
lines
any of those graphs will correspond to
the same depth first search tree when
you're exploring the graph
so so it says that whenever you have
uh
if you know about uh
early ways of getting trees with a
certain number of versions then you know
about all the ways of having connected
graphs because uh every graph has a
depth first search tree
uh
algebraically what that means is this uh
if i take the
this formula that i had for inversions
uh
on a tree with four vertices i convert
that and i put a one i change x to one
plus w
uh which means uh uh it's an orange
vertex it's either there or not one
means no
no i'm sorry an edge orange edge is
either there or not so one means don't
put the orange edge in w means put it in
if i take one plus w squared that has
means i have two orange edges
two inversions two large edges and so i
either have uh uh
uh you know i either include both of
them or one of them or
or either and so on so by replacing x by
one plus w you you get the effect of of
saying choose whether these each of
these orange edges is either there or
not
smaller than the ancestor the immediate
ancestor let's take a look at that
the orange edges go to those things that
are smaller than the immediate so so the
zero one comes from the inversion zero
to nine right is that what you're saying
here there's four of them so two for
example has eight above it so it goes to
everything less to me
two goes to everything less than eight
that's above it
all right yeah yeah and that also
corresponds to the depth first search
rule
says that uh because like when you're at
two you would you would you would
definitely go to eight first before you
try any of these others and then
okay and then uh those others would get
explored
in the tree okay so that's the that's
the connection and that's the uh
correspondence of uh ira gessel and
dalinghuang
now uh
algebraically then i have a connection
between these mysterious inversion
polynomials that i wanted and connected
graphs for example in this case i
expanded out and i would get 16 i
multiplied by w cubed that's the number
of edges in the tree that's the number
of black edges here is the is uh n minus
one and then uh if there's if there's
ten vertices you need nine edges to
connect them in a tree and then you add
these other orange edges which might be
in the graph
so connected graphs with four vertices
there are uh they can all be described
in this way there are 16 of them that
are that have only three edges 15 of
them have four edges six have five edges
and one has all six possible edges
between the four
vertices um
and the and the other graphs on four
vertices uh aren't connected
that's the correspondence of wong and
gessel
so so along so the uh the one the so if
i know that there are three inversions
that means that i have three orange arcs
to put in
and that means i want w
one plus w cubed because each orange arc
is either one which means not there or
or w which means there and then it gets
counted in the edges
um
when i count uh
see if i sum over all connected graphs
um w to the number of edges that w is is
uh standing for saying include the edge
and the w cube here says include the
black edges the uh so so all together i
get all connected graphs
have to be one of these patterns i'll
connect the graphs on zero one two three
um
let me just uh do it again suppose like
somebody gives you a connected graph on
zero one two three do a depth first
search in that graph starting at zero
that tells you what tree you have then
that tree
has a certain number of inversions in it
those inversions will tell you where to
put the orange edges
and and if it have three inversions
it'll tell you that that this is the
number this is the that you're going to
have three or you're just coming like
this and so and so uh uh
so so so going from the from the
connected graphs
to to all trees which you get by depth
first search and then by plugging
one plus w in for x you get a formula
relating
a formula for all connected graphs by
the number of edges they have
if you know the formula for all
trees by the number of inversions they
have
right uh so so that so there's this
relation between the uh the inversions
and the
and the graphs
now and that's uh
uh a beautiful thing that was that was
noticed um in
the in the 70s
now
it remained for me to do one last step
and as to put this together
and connect it to linear probing because
i happen to know that the same
polynomial occurs in linear probing at
least uh you know it it's it's all these
numbers check out the same it's
god wouldn't have wanted it to be a
different problem so it's got to be this
way so so um
now uh so
let's consider
the generating function for all graphs
connected or not
that have m edges and n vertices and so
i i had w to the m stands for
having m edges z to the n
over n factorial says that it has n
vertices that are labeled
with integers uh now similarly uh c
would be to generate the same thing
except now i restrict myself not to all
graphs but only to the connected graphs
the ones that you can get from any
vertex to another by path of edges
um and
what we've got from the
uh
from simple uh
uh reasoning it is a
is a known formula for g
because
uh
there's only n times n minus one over
two pairs of vertices
that's the number of ways you can have
an edge so so you get all graphs just by
taking one plus w to that to that number
i mean all graphs and four vertices one
plus w to the four to the sixth power
because each each of the possible six
edges is either there or not
and so that's g
so so so i can i i can easily you know
tell um mathematica to uh uh to uh to
give me you know expand out this
polynomial and that'll list me all all
graphs uh
um on a certain number of edges but the
the interesting connection between the
graphs and the connected graphs is given
by this formula
that the g function is just x e to the c
this is a formula discovered by some
physicists in the 50s
and it's basic to uh to this whole
symbolic method
and uh
it so it turns out whenever you have a a
combinatorial system that can break down
into components
that are unordered with respect to each
other
then you get a formula like this so uh
graphs are are a good example a graph
always breaks down into connected
components
either the graph is connected or it has
two components or three components or
something like that it has two
components uh
they are components in either order and
so the factorials
it sort of
if you expand this out it says g is
equal to one plus c plus c squared over
2 plus c cubed over
6
plus c 4 over 4 factorial and so on it
just says that all graphs are obtained
either by having no components or one
component or two components but you
divide by two because they could be
either either order
either a b or b a or it could have three
components and so you put you divide by
six and so on and so g is equal to e to
the c
uh and this means uh that i i i know g
and i know this formula so i know c i
just take the logarithm of g
and and you can spew this out uh uh uh
you know so so mathematical compute this
instantly and give you the
the coefficients of the
uh the number of graphs with it with any
number of edges that you want
um but now if i convert this but i
happen to know that c is also
uh
related to the inversion uh of trees by
the formula we had a minute ago and so
um
therefore i know my f function f is the
key to linear probing uh it has to be
related in this way to all these
values
and putting it all together i get this
rather
elegant formula for f as a quotient of
two polynomials
um f of one plus w and z is this uh
is this thing where uh the numerator
denominator looked almost the same until
i have a plus sign here and a minus sign
there
um
well
uh actually that's a very beautiful
formula but it doesn't that it doesn't
solve the problem at all because i don't
know how to work with a formula like
this
it's a it's a it's just elegant
uh that's all it's not useful
unfortunately
um
however
the beauty of it was that
that without knowing that that that
several years ago
i worked on the problem of studying
connected graphs
and uh
and it's especially graphs that don't
have very many edges
and uh in fact i gave one of these
computer amusing lectures just about
that very topic called the birth of the
giant component maybe some of you were
here
and uh
and so i actually knew a lot about this
generating function in another way
and this goes back to work
of
professor wright that many people know
by the book of hardy and wright on
number theory or he
also did pioneering work on counting
graphs that have a small number of edges
that are connected
and
this paper came out in
1977 and and uh
and in there he he presented a way of
attacking this this generating function
that's going to lead to the solution to
the problem and uh and then when i
when i started working on this uh this
is a paper from 1993
um which is the longest paper i ever
wrote
and it's it's in the entire issue of
this journal was was this paper
um i don't know 150 pages or something
like that and uh anyway it's it's a
giant paper it's called a giant
component and
and uh uh but without knowing it all the
work that i did in that paper on the
giant component was directly relevant to
to well not all of it a lot of it was
directly relevant to this problem of
linear probing which had been my first
algorithm i ever analyzed
so let me explain a little bit this
connection in that paper we we discuss
all connected graphs
and we break the generating function
down into
into uh different different
components the first uh different parts
of the of the of the connected graphs a
connected graph either is an unrooted
tree
which means it has uh n vertices n minus
one edges like ten vertices nine edges
then it's a tree
without a root or it's what you call a
unicycle
which means it has the same number of
vertices as edges
and there will be one loop in it
or it's a bicycle which means it has one
more edge
uh and it has two cycles in it or
tricycle or so on and so there are there
are uh so so if you take a look at at
this big generating function for all
connected graph c you break it down into
the terms that that have uh one the
power of w is one less than the power of
z or the power of w and z are equal or
the w this has one more two more and so
on you break it down into parts like
that and
uh that um
uh
is something which we can actually deal
with uh each of these parts we know a
lot about trees unicycles bicycles they
tend to get more complicated the higher
the power of w here in the front now
suppose we had this expansion
then i calculate f of one plus w z
uh
just by using taylor's theorem i mean uh
you can
you can differentiate it and set w equal
to one so so uh
uh the power
the coefficients
uh
are related in this way by changing w to
one plus w
um
and
now
so if i so so it turns out then that
that knowing the these these views
um
are going to give me the key to the
uv and w and x are going to give me the
key to f which is the function that i
need
um now
for example the derivative of u of u of
z u is the generating function for
unrooted trees and and the symbolic
method tells you that if you take the
derivative you get
uh rooted trees uh the derivative of a
of an expression sort of says uh
you have the combinatorial object but
you also point to something in that
object so a tree under the tree and you
point to one of its vertices you've got
a rooted tree
so
so
that generating function is called t of
z
generating function for rooted trees
then v prime v is the
is for unicycles but it would be a
rooted
cycle with a with with with it with a
designated vertex it turns out that we
can describe those by
uh t
cubed over over this anyway and all
these other terms that turn out are
expressible in terms of a certain
function called t the tree function
which is a which is uh
uh one of my favorite functions
the generating function for all rooted
trees
um in fact if you look at at the um
at the second edition of third edition
of volume one of art of computer
programming this is a book that came out
in
in july and uh
um makes an excellent christmas present
and uh
and uh bookstore is selling at 15 off
until the end of october
uh anyway uh here's a uh
here's a paragraph from that uh uh
here's where it introduces the the tree
the generating function for rooted trees
and um
and and then it's then it refers to uh
you know um
a long survey paper about uh the
properties of this function and then it
also refers here to uh this book by
about commentary species and three-like
structures even before the book came out
you see how up-to-date my new
my new addition is if i can refer to
this book even before it's out
um so now the tree function anyway is is
is is great and i i i don't want to
belabor this but i want to explain that
once we know the tree function
uh we can express everything in terms of
of of trees
and the symbolic method gives us our
expression for
for
for my magic f function in terms of t
over z
times another function of of w and the
treat the t function and the um and r is
is p over one minus t
uh
and uh that stands for a path of trees
and uh
uh
the expansion is like this the
the first term is w i squared over two
pretty simple the second term gets more
hairy the third term gets hairier yet
but there's a pattern to this there's a
method to this madness there's magic
coefficients five twenty fourths one
fourth
five sixteenths fifty five forty eights
and so on some numbers that turn out to
be very
very um magical and i talked about them
in one of my previous musings but there
they are in my paper on the giant
component so i know all those
coefficients
uh which means i'm ready to solve the
problem about um about linear probing uh
here's the answer um
the f function
is equal to t over z times this and so i
want to get i want to look at the
coefficient of z to the n in f of one
plus w
and and by some algebra
um you can convert that
first to use this formula
uh and just plug in but now um
i
have z to the n minus n in the
denominator so i instead of looking at
the coefficient of v to the n i want to
look at z to the m
um and then there's a wonderful property
of the tree function that is if you want
to look at the coefficient of z to the m
in this it's equal to the coefficient of
z to the n in this other function
and
that's uh
lagrange's inversion formula which is
something that we learn in the
in the study of the symbolic method
leads us finally now uh
i mean basically uh
i uh we have to step back and look at
and see the forest and not just the
trees so
here's the theory that comes out it says
the expected value of this
displacement
choose 2 which means displacement times
displacement minus 1 over 2 when n keys
are hashing to m cells with linear
probing is
the coefficient of w squared z to the n
in this
in this function divided by the same
thing
uh with w set to uh
you know just plug in one instead for w
set to zero
and we can and by using the formula
since i only have to look at up to w
squared uh the formulas are are fairly
easy to to get and we can and we can
describe it
in terms of
some functions that we that were known
to be important
from the analysis i did originally 35
years ago
well
it's a long story but
i can summarize it like this
there's
there's amazing connections between
linear probing
uh this this problem of musical chairs
and depth first search in graphs
uh
we went from
musical chairs to trees with inversions
to graphs
and depth first search and graphs
another one of the
main important algorithms of computer
science
using these connections and the study
and the
things that are then known about random
graphs
we can analyze all moments of the
distribution of total displacement
before
um you know last year
nobody knew how to
look at the uh
at this the the
the average of the square of the
displacement now we can do the cube
displacement and so on
and it's all because we know how to
analyze random graphs and so since we
connect linear probing to graphs we can
analyze the this the probing problem in
terms of what we know about graphs grass
and
it's
over the period of 35 years there's been
tremendous advances in techniques that
made this possible almost easy that's i
think i'm overstating that a little bit
but uh
but uh uh at this siam meeting this
summer john hennessy gave a talk
uh write a talk just before mine and and
uh john uh
in his talk uh went back um not 35 years
but 40 years to the computers that were
that were announced uh 40 years uh
earlier which when siam uh again you
know
was
just founded it was his 40th anniversary
and so john uh pointed out that uh
he looked at the specs of the computers
and he pointed out that the computers
have gotten better by nine orders of
magnitude
well so uh i couldn't match that
but i think that uh in this 35 years for
analysis of algorithms i think we might
have gone uh
two intellectual orders of magnitude uh
further as far as the knowledge that's
been gained in the 35 years and i think
uh that that uh you know the the
the things that that we we can now do
with the symbolic method were
unthinkable um
uh
15 years ago and just becoming beginning
to be predicted that we could do it uh
maybe 10 years ago and now
um and now it seems that uh
in two different continents to say this
problem was solved in the same week
using the using the method
okay thanks very much for listening
you